[Musique]
elle est anesthésiée
derrière
[Musique]
vous en saurez combien
onze espèces blue est la dernière du
genre vous ne pourrez jamais la capture
et vous savez peut-être qui pourrait
nous aider
une mission de sauvetage qu'est ce qu'on
risque un lieu clos il me connaît il
avec moi tu sais que tu peux pas rester
ici
rappelez-vous somme toute secte ils
m'ont menti
l'homme qui a prouvé que les raptor
peuvent obéir vous ne vous êtes jamais
demandé combien le million vaudrait un
prédateur dressé
ils vont les vendre table où ils ont
d'autres projets pour elle c'est quoi
cette chose mon cri c'est la créature la
plus dangereuse qui ait jamais existé
je propose qu'on arrête ce délire
[Musique]
et ouais tu pense comme moi
on a libéré la puissance génétique on ne
peut plus faire marche arrière
blow
si je reviens pas
n'oublie pas que c'est toi qui m'a
demandé de venir ici je vais m'en sortir
ces créatures étaient là bien avant et
si on n'y prend pas garde
ils seront encore là bien après
bienvenue à jurassic world
[Musique]